[Music]
we all have our ways of making the world
a better place
helping others feel welcome in a new
game
is one i'll give you a little tour this
is a big server you're gonna need a
tourist
okay let's go ahead let's go ahead and
get out of this spawn this is fog
oh no
what is that what
have you done making sure your teammates
can learn from their mistakes
is another well i didn't got me i i
didn't feed anyone
i didn't feed anyone because they didn't
[ __ ] do anything either bro
letting your fellow humans know that
they are heard during their most
difficult most vulnerable moments can
also be useful
shut the [ __ ] up in the background
but all jokes aside benjamin lupo
better known as dr lupo actually does
all of those things and a whole lot more
i got a message that you uh you wanted
to play some video games you challenged
me to a 1v1 yes
you uh play with yourself i
i that's a different website i think
from exploding onto the scene in pub g
to becoming one of the biggest names in
fortnite
dr lupo never lost sight of what was
important the best thing that i can do
with this channel is help
impact people in a positive way so how
is it that a small time
destiny streamer ended up making it onto
time magazine's list of the
25 most influential people on the
internet is dr lupo
an actual doctor and is he really
the nicest most wholesome guy on the
whole of twitch
[Music]
okay guys so before we dive into lupo's
story please take a second
to like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications
that way more people watch our videos
more ad revenue and then
who knows maybe i'll get a gillette
commercial of my own now if there's
one thing you need to know about dr lupo
it's that he's a devoted husband
and parent but his role as patriarch
extends far beyond his own family you
see
over the years lupo's become something
of a father figure to
all of twitch went to the zoo this
morning and found a baguette in a cage
pretty sure it was bread in captivity
[Music]
and as with any dad lupo is down to show
new players the ropes i don't want a
handhold if you don't want me to
handhold
um you know it's because i know you and
i
i know that you you are usually the type
that very much likes to like
throw yourself at it and learn it and so
for you i was basically what my plan was
was to be available as a resource
and then if you had questions you just
fire away and i will answer
he also isn't shy about making his
disappointment
known oh this guy's just rushed in here
and like any self-respecting papa dr
lupo is
truly there for the people he cares
about
no matter what they're going through
d-a-v-y underscore w-a-v-y with the ten
said
ending at all so i figured i'd give my
favorite stream in my last 10 hope it
all goes well in the future please don't
do that
in chat right now there's a suicide
helpline please call that right now
national suicide prevention lifeline
please call that right now
pick the 1-800-273-8255 up and call it i
don't know if it's real or not i don't
know if what you're saying is real or
not
call it now dealing with a situation
like that
gracefully couldn't have been easy but
because
lupo is able to deftly navigate the good
the bad and the ugly his eventual
internet stardom as a streamer seemed
like
destiny and funnily enough destiny
was how he actually got into streaming
in the first place
lupo dabbled in a few other games and
eventually made twitch partner by 2016
which was cool and all but wasn't
incentive enough for him to drop his day
job as a
systems engineer for an insurance
company in omaha
i was a senior systems engineer i worked
in i.t so i liked the virtual
machine automation stuff network
security all that
but all of that changed when lupo lobbed
a grenade at a certain paintbrush-haired
streamer's face
during a game of pubg holy crap i just
killed ninja with a grenade
and i lose my mind and my chant my
stream goes from my 400 viewers
sky rock is like 2 000 in probably about
15 seconds because everybody came over
like oh my god dude you just killed me
with a grenade it was
the most amazing thing now the incident
between lupo and ninja
might have appeared fleeting but it was
actually the start
of a beautiful friendship he and i
started playing together and
things just they just clicked and so i
had i had started
to become friends with with a very very
good player
and somebody who now behind the scenes
is by far one of my best friends
and his transition into playing fortnite
with ninja and other big content
creators
and streaming full-time meant that the
possibilities
were now endless
no way no way no [ __ ] way
no way i shot it between a crack and the
boards in the [ __ ] shack wall
it also opened a lot of doors for dr
lupo doors he intended to use to do some
good for not only the gaming community
but the world at large on my channel we
raised 1.3 million dollars in a full
year which is insane
i wanted to know specifically where all
that was going
because i didn't want i want to be able
to convince
people to go bigger next year the
mainstream media came to know dr lupo as
a driving force behind raising
millions of dollars for saint jude's
children's hospital
and he was even named as one of time
magazine's 25 most influential people on
the internet
in 2019. lupo was also able to pay
tribute to his late father
and namesake the actual dr james lupo
in front of thousands of people when he
was recognized for his charitable
efforts
so i give him a ring and i'm telling him
about a brand deal i had that friday it
was
a monday morning and uh told him
us i was playing a mobile game for for
some stupid
you know at the time it was a stupid
amount of money it's like 10 grand
and i i'd like to imagine he'd say the
same thing looking at how much money
we've raised for st jude and the fact
that you guys are here and giving me
this award and everything and
his exact words after i told him the
number were what the [ __ ]
you see lupo's natural ability to
combine
the gravitas of a deeply personal memory
with the humor required to recount it to
a room
full of strangers without making it
awkward is part of what draws viewers to
him
but not everybody who tuned in was there
simply to
enjoy the stream as his viewership
exploded
like a rebellious teenager lupo's fan
base
began to act out from comments about his
looks that forced him to temporarily
turn his camera off
to accusations of not doing enough about
racism in chat
the dad of twitch has had to put his
foot down
and discipline his fans on more than one
occasion
you looking at me and saying [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] your friends after everything
that i've done for this channel
after everything that i've done for
people that watch this after everything
of my income that i've given away that
you don't even [ __ ] know about
have you come in here and say [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] your friends to [ __ ] me bro
you can go [ __ ] yourself kids will
occasionally pick fights with their
parents
but thankfully in the case of lupo he
was willing to put in the extra
effort to help his chat do and be
better and fortunately for the most part
they were willing to listen you need to
listen up and pay attention
okay i said that there that my
following list on twitch was whitewashed
and it was
and so i went through with the help of a
couple people and i'm gonna try and not
say any names so nobody thinks i'm
trying to target anybody i went through
and i followed a
whole ton of quality content creators
on twitch that are not white because my
[ __ ] was whitewashed
it was it was a problem and i resolved
it but while lupo
seems like a paragon of virtue among
streamers
he does have another side to him as well
a mischievous
fun-loving and occasionally savage
side you know a lot of the people here
that are here in front of us are our
viewers
which is what actually amazes me about
you tyler that you're up here because
most of your viewers are outside because
of the age restriction
[Laughter]
tfu he's learned so much from watching
me play on my stream great to see him
excelling here today i think everybody
has jack as far as eating burritos goes
but today we're here talking about
competitive fortnite
you look like a rejected member of a
lesbian biker gang
as dr lupo's fortnight fandom began to
wane
he started to play other games to keep
his fans tuning in
and between all the brightly colored
offerings like fall guys and among us
there was one notable murky spot where
that
dark side i mentioned could come out to
play
escape from tarkov last night i
sleep maybe three hours
we get up we shoot men
now this is not to say that lupo broke
bad in tarkov or anything
but all that hyperrealistic violence
definitely took a toll on him
[Applause]
thank you so just [ __ ] friend
they're both dead
they're dead you got him
yeah i got him
i just jumped i i opened the door and
then i walked in and i shot him in the
face because i'm their [ __ ] dad
bloody massacres aside lupo stayed
true to his usual self he might have
been busy eviscerating his enemies
but his sense of humor remained
indestructible hey chad
you know my salty nuts in your mouth
well check out tennesseepeanut.com
the pov from my side looks like you're
absolutely jerking it against the wall
absolutely jerking it against the wall
bud get it yeah
wait wait are you looking at the hose
19-inch
beaded anal snake yeah it's it's an anal
snake dude it's not even
the best seller it's not even a toy
anymore now this wasn't the first time
that lupo had
indulged his dark urges in fact
he'd played tarkov years ago when the
game's player base was much smaller
but since then tarkov's popularity had
increased
substantially and when twitch drops were
added by the end of 2019
it became a much bigger deal on the
platform and being that lupo wasn't some
fresh-faced
scrub who was unfamiliar with the game's
basics
he had a big advantage over a lot of
streamers who were just
discovering tarkov for the first time
and his viewership
only benefited from it but just because
lupo knew a thing or two about the game
didn't mean that he wouldn't
occasionally get tarkoffed
like the rest of us
what the [ __ ] is happening
this is escape from tarkov
a game which you will devote literally
hundreds thousands of hours to getting
very good at only to be
struck down in your prime repeatedly by
the game itself
you just die and die and die
you keep coming back for more because
you [ __ ] hate yourself inside
you love the pain though you could feed
on it
to my left i got a [ __ ] gun jam i got
a [ __ ] goddamn
oh
as one of tarkov's biggest streamers
lupo
found himself being added into its
hellish world as an
easter egg that's right when rummaging
through certain locations in tarkov you
may actually stumble across a can of dr
lupo's coffee beans i have almost a
thousand hours on this game and
this is the first time i've got lupo's
beans man now for most people
tarkov is already a frustratingly
difficult experience
but the thing about lupo is that he is a
true
glutton for punishment and to up the
ante
he basically created his own new game
mode
the snowball challenge the challenge
being that if you die before killing the
bosses
you basically have to start from scratch
and this [ __ ]
is not for the faint of heart
damn it
he had the little pistol i didn't
realize he had a glock that was a big
boy gun
oh man close that was dude
we've had such good moments already such
good moments but i can't i was
like so close even though his fellow
tarkov streamers like landmark and
pastilli could pull it off
it was an incredibly difficult task and
after its most recent wipe
dr lupo reflected on the bizarre
relationship he has with the game
that no matter how much time he devotes
to tarkov
it takes serious dedication to stay
committed to something that's basically
been designed to make you
want to rage quit but refrain from
actually doing it
it's like the dark souls of of fps games
yeah
it should be a giant grueling pain in
the ass
every time you play it but it should
also be it should be
enticing and immersive but despite how
conflicted
dr lupo feels about the game it doesn't
seem like he has any plans to
permanently
escape from tarkov anytime soon and
while he may not be the absolute
greatest player out there
he certainly has a few tricks up his
sleeve it's a player right there this
guy running down to us
uh standing with fence increased i
killed him got another guy in the back
behind him that was a crispy one
that was okay to kill him yeah
apparently dr lupo's special blend of
wholesome yet real yet skill based
entertainment has kept him at the top of
twitch's stat charts
for years and now tarkov has become a
consistent source of both
inspiration and frustration that has
kept him afloat in the fickle world
of streaming
yeah it's right above me no they're on
second floor
i think something just went off behind
me in real life
oh in real life holy [ __ ] yeah
uh that was really bright did you hear
that
no i didn't a whole lot well i mean a
lot of things were going on so
my eyes are watering now now obviously
tarkov and lupo won't be around forever
but for as long as they are this combo
is gonna have people coming back for
more
hey little guy come on little guy
[Laughter]
from playing games with celebrities to
using his
own celebrity status to help others lupo
has become the
face of positivity on a platform that
often thrives on toxicity even if he did
have to step over a few bodies to get
there
you ready let's [ __ ] go baby
destiny was actually how he got into
streaming in the first
first place in the first place
colin firth michael i can't do michael
caine i can't do michael caine
michael he's from rotherhithe
how the [ __ ] you say this rotherhead
rather rotherhive